[Música]
muchos instrumentos musicales modernos
son incómodos o voluminosos algunos
necesitan un soporte o un taburete pero
el cajón es un tambor un soporte y un
asiento todo en una cómoda caja y esa
simplicidad puede ser la clave de su
trayectoria entre culturas para
convertirse en uno de los instrumentos
de percusión más populares actualmente
la historia del cajón comienza en África
occidental donde los indígenas tenían
tradiciones musicales entradas en
tambores y
danzas cuando muchos de ellos fueron
llevados a América como esclavos
trajeron con ellos esta cultura pero sin
sus instrumentos nativos tuvieron que
improvisar los esclavos africanos en la
costa de Perú no tenían los materiales
ni la posibilidad de construir uno de
sus tambores tradicionales como un yembe
o un dunun pero sí tenían un montón de
cajas no solo había muchas disponibles
sino que su aspecto discreto ayudaba a
eludir las leyes que prohibían Tocar
música a los
esclavos los primeros cajones peruanos
se hacían con una caja con cinco lados
sólidos de madera el sexto lado hecho de
una capa de madera más delgada se usó
como superficie para el golpe más
conocida como tapa por detrás se hizo un
agujero para liberar el
sonido
con el desarrollo de la cultura
afroperuana aparecieron nuevas formas
musicales y nuevos bailes como la zacca
el festejo y el Land y el cajón se
convirtió en un instrumento musical por
derecho
propio los primeros cambios incluyeron
simplemente doblar las tablas de la caja
para ajustar el sonido y con La
abolición de la esclavitud y la
masificación del cajón llegaron más
improvisaciones y
experimentaciones vez la persona más
activa en la introducción del cajón al
público europeo fue el guitarrista
flamenco español Paco de Lucía de gira
en Perú en
1977 Él y su percusionista Rubén dantas
descubrieron el cajón y lo llevaron a
España reconociendo su potencial de uso
en la música
flamenca al estirar las cuerdas de la
guitarra por la parte interior de la
tapa los músicos de flamenco pudieron
crear un sonido similar al
redoblante esto dio al cajón un sonido
cercano a un set de
batería el cajón se extendió rápidamente
y se convirtió en estándar no solo en el
flamenco sino en géneros como el folk
jazz blues y
Rock hoy muchos de los cajones
especializados se fabrican con cuerdas
ajustables con múltiples superficies de
juego y cont
tensores pero el concepto básico sigue
siendo el mismo y la historia del cajón
muestra que las cosas más simples pueden
tener El potencial más increíble si se
piensan de forma
[Música]
creativa le interesa aprender a tocar un
instrumento permítanos ayudarle a
aprender a leer música con este video y
no olvide suscribirse a nuestro
canal y